in this video we'll be talking about
Jack stat signaling pathway this is a
very important cell signaling pathway
which is important in context of
development physiology and in terms of
disease so Jack stat signaling pathway
begins with the cell surface receptor
which are most commonly The cyto
receptors so cytokine binds to these
receptors leading to its dimerization so
these are the membrane surface
events so these receptors B to Jack or
jenus kyes so these are kyes enzymes
which obviously phosphorate Downstream
targets the first thing the Jax
phosphorate is the receptor
itself so the receptor phosphorilation
is done by Jack and this is kind of
similar but also different from the
receptor tyrosin kyes in the receptor
tyrosin kyes the kyes activity was
intrinsic but in case of Jack signaling
path way the Kines activity was not
intrinsic to the receptor the Jack are
soluble proteins which Associates with
the activated receptor and phosphorate
the
receptor so this is the different part
now after phosphorilation of the
receptor specific signal transduction
proteins known as stats can bind to
these phosphorilated
receptors now once stat binds to this
phosphorilated receptor Jack can further
phosphorilated the stat molecules stat
stands for Signal transducer and
activator of transcription so more or
less it's a transcription Factor so
phosphorilated stat can dimerize either
homod dimerize or heterodimerize and
eventually translocate into the
nucleus thereby it can bind to specific
regions known as cyto response elements
after binding to cytokine response
elements it would recruit RNA polymerase
and eventually lead to activation of
many
genes and these Gene categories would be
described in subsequent slides so the
question is the jack stat signaling
formula is same for all the cells so
where does heterogenity occurs so the
heterogenity occurs based on the type of
Jack used or the type of stat is
involved in the signaling there are
different type of Jacks and stats that
are Downstream to different signaling
pathway for example if you look at this
particular slide you can see
il4 receptor binds to Jack 1 and Jack 3
in contrast interferon gamma receptor
binds to Jack one and Jack 2 and they
also activate different stat where
whereas where you can see il4 activates
stat 6 the interferon receptor gamma
activates actually Stat one homodimers
so obviously these heterogeneous
outcomes lead to the difference es in
cellular
responses so now let's talk about the
termination of jaat signaling pathway
because initiation of any signaling
pathway is important but the termination
is more important to overcome the risk
of um uncontrolled signaling so there
are particular different strategies by
which the jaad signaling pathway can be
terminated there are specific
phosphatases known as protein tyrosine
phosphatases that can chop off the
phosphate phosphate group from the
receptor and rendering this particular
signaling pathway inactive there are
other strategies like receptor mediated
endocytosis of The receptors so that
reduce the number of receptors available
for binding to the signal also there
could be other proteins which can
possibly degrade the Jack or Stat or
even the receptor so these are known as
suppressor of cyto signaling protein or
SS proteins that can potentially degrade
the receptor and degrade the jack with
combination of other molecules now let's
talk about the Jack stat pathway in
context of interferon signaling so we
have some understanding about the
Immunology as well so interferons are
alarming molecules that are secreted by
a viral infected cells so these
interferon molecules are recepted by
specific receptors on the neighboring
cell and that act that gives the
neighboring cell time and the necess
necessary um proteins to counter a viral
attack so interferon signaling is
mediated by Jack stat so interferon
receptor Alpha and beta or Al or gamma
receptors bind to specific interferons
and they activate jaat signaling pathway
and note that here this there are
specific Jacks which are Downstream to
each of these signaling receptors
ultimately they bind to cyto receptor
cyto response elements and give rise to
genes but the question is which genes so
let us break that down so first of all
one of the gene that is getting
activated is protein kyese R so
ultimately protein kyes R enzyme is
produced this particular enzyme actually
interacts with the viral DNA and
eventually inhibits its uh forther
Downstream processes also protein kind
is Arc and phosphorilated elongation
Factor 2 a which blocks the translation
so if the viral genes cannot be
transcribed cannot be translated virus
would eventually die so these are some
antiviral responses similarly there are
other molecules such as oligo as
syntheis this particular molecule
process viral mRNA in such a way that
they are more prone to degradation
another protein known as MX protein
which oligomerize and inhibits the V
viral particle assembly so various
aspects of viral life processes are
hindered by this particular Gene
products this is how Jack stat signaling
ensures interferon response is uh
augmented now let's talk about the Jack
signaling pathway as a therapeutic uh
Target so there are specific Inhibitors
which Target the Jack stat signaling
pathway which inhibits the cyto
production one such in inhibitor is
known as tofas CIB this particular
inhibitor is used for several autoimmune
disorder treatment like rheumatoid
arthritis this particular inhibitor is a
competitive inhibitor for Jack molecule
so which renders the entire signaling
arm in in inactive and it prevents the
production of the cytokine so how tastin
interacts with the particular Jack so
this is how the Jack overall look like
it has kindness domain domain sh2 domain
and the F domain so ATP has to bind to
the KY domain in order for the jack to
phosphorate but in this case tofas City
actually competitively inhibit ATP and
binds instead and thereby inactivating
the Jack activity and this is how it is
really important therapeutic Target so I
hope this video was useful informative
enough so if you like this video please
share it with your friends don't forget
to put your suggestions in the comment
and and all my social media links are
provided in the description see you in
the next video but before that you can
also support our Channel using super
thanks please help us your one or $2
motivation uh contribution would be our
motivation to do such videos thank you
and see you in the next
video